Let's lock down the API design questions. Three items: REST versus GraphQL, versioning strategy, and rate limiting.
I'll start with GraphQL since I know it comes up. Our enterprise customers want predictable, documented endpoints they can hand to their integration teams.
They read OpenAPI specs. GraphQL is a learning curve for them and an unknown for our SDK generation story. I'd lean REST.
Agreed from the engineering side. GraphQL adds complexity we don't need yet. We have maybe six external integrations on the roadmap — REST handles all of them cleanly.
REST it is. Well-understood, easy to document, easier to cache. We revisit if we hit flexibility problems two or three years out.
Decision: REST API. No GraphQL in the initial platform.
Versioning next. Do we prefix from day one or bolt it on later?
From day one, absolutely. I have seen the pain of retrofitting versioning onto a live API. Customers hate breaking changes and you cannot avoid them without version namespacing.
Agreed. Slash-api-slash-v1 from the first endpoint we ship. Cheap to do now, expensive to fix later.
Are we documenting with OpenAPI automatically or manually? I want to make sure customer integrations have good docs.
FastAPI generates it automatically from type annotations. We get Swagger UI and ReDoc for free. That's part of why we chose FastAPI — docs are not a separate effort.
And we can publish the spec to a public URL for enterprise customers who want to generate their own SDK wrappers.
Decision: slash-api-slash-v1 prefix from day one. Auto-generated OpenAPI docs.
Rate limiting. What's the default? I need a number to build against before I write the API key management flow.
I talked to the sales team last week. Enterprise customers expect at least a hundred calls per minute per API key as a baseline. Anything lower gets flagged in security reviews.
One hundred per minute per API key works. Higher tiers get more. We implement it at the API gateway level, not in FastAPI, so we can change it without a redeploy. AWS API Gateway handles this natively.
That works. Keeps the rate limit logic out of the application layer entirely. I'll spec the API key management flow this sprint — should be one story.
Should we document that rate limiting is enforced at the gateway? Customers are going to ask when they hit a 429.
Yes. Add it to the API reference docs. Decision: one hundred requests per minute per API key, enforced at API gateway. David owns the API key management flow.
I'll add a clear 429 error body with retry-after header. Makes it easier for customers to handle in their integrations.
Good call. I'll draft the rate limit section of the API docs once David has the error format settled.
That's all three. REST, v1 from day one, hundred-per-minute rate limit. Clean session. Sara will get the notes.